well now to Abby Lee Miller one year
after her emergency spinal surgery the
dance mom is making news again yes for
the extremely powerful photo that showed
us where she's been and what she's been
through here's the photo Abby with her
hair shaped short a dramatic scar
running the length of her back on full
display The Dance Moms star has endured
ten rounds of chemotherapy to combat
lymphoma and she has another surgery to
go the 52 year-old has been confined to
a wheelchair since her spinal surgery
and captioned this post I struggled
through months of physical therapy to
learn to sit up again to crawl and maybe
with a miracle
someday I'll walk still Abby Lee's
spirit remains high she's back to work
on the new season of Dance Moms preview
show she's still the same Abby a source
close to the production tells et today
quote getting back to work on the new
season has given Abby a new purpose and
her passion for dance is stronger than
ever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]